bitcoin critics for a long time have
been talking about the fact that they
believe the u.s government and other
governments around the world are going
to ban ownership of bitcoin now of
course there is precedent for government
stepping in and banning ownership of
assets go back to the 1933 there was an
executive order that the president
signed and eventually there was multiple
pieces of legislation put forward that
forced americans to stop hoarding gold
the idea was that the federal reserve
needed access to more gold and they
couldn't shut down gold production and
so instead they actually needed to ramp
up their access and so what they said
was you as a private citizen are not
allowed to hoard gold you must turn it
in there was a fixed price right around
20 at the time they said you have to
give us your gold we'll pay you for it
and then you are not allowed to hoard it
moving forward and so these bitcoin
critics they've been saying the same
thing that the government the central
bank and militaries around the world
they may not be able to shut down the
bitcoin network but actually what we
should anticipate is that those
governments are going to move in and
they're going to ban ownership of
bitcoin now of course this seems kind of
outrageous in today's day and age that a
government would move in to actually ban
ownership of an asset especially when
politicians hold the asset our largest
financial institutions hold the asset
and other nation states around the world
are starting to adopt it as legal tender
well the bitcoin critics didn't see what
happened yesterday coming
yesterday a sitting u.s congressman
representative tom emmer put forward a
proposal not to ban bitcoin ownership
but actually to ban the federal reserve
from issuing directly to american
citizens a central bank digital currency
that's right the u.s sitting congressman
did not ban bitcoin instead he is trying
to ban a central bank digital currency
he said as other countries like china
develop cbdc's that fundamentally omit
the benefits and protections of cash it
is more important than ever to ensure
the united states is digital currency
policy protects financial privacy
maintains the dollar's dominance and
cultivates innovation he then said
cbdc's that fail to adhere to these
three basic principles could enable an
entity like the federal reserve to
mobilize itself into a retail bank
collect personally identifiable
information on users and track their
transactions indefinitely not only does
this cbdc model raise single point of
failure issues leaving americans
financial information vulnerable to
attack but it could be used as a
surveillance tool that americans should
never be forced to tolerate from their
own government requiring users to open
an account at the fed to access the
united states cbdc would put the fed as
an insidious path akin to china's
digital authoritarianism
any cbdc implemented by the fed must be
open permissionless and private this
means that any digital dollar must be
accessible to all transact on a
blockchain that is transparent to all
and maintain the privacy elements of
cash in order to maintain the dollar
status as the world's reserve currency
in a digital age it is important that
the united states leads with a posture
that prioritizes innovation and does not
aim to compete with the private sector
simply put we must prioritize blockchain
technology with american characteristics
rather than mimic china
digital authoritarianism out of fear
this is absolutely fascinating this is a
sitting u.s politician who is saying the
united states
we have to preserve financial privacy we
have to encourage innovation and we have
to continue to be the shining light on a
global stage for economic prosperity a
central bank digital currency if used
incorrectly would actually violate those
three principles it could actually hurt
the us dollars global reserve status it
could infringe on americans financial
privacy and it could actually decelerate
our pace of innovation china is serving
as the example of exactly what
authoritarian governments want to do
they want to use it for financial
surveillance they want to prevent their
citizens from doing certain things
that's not what the principles that
america was built on america shouldn't
implement a central bank digital
currency if that's what we're going to
do
the federal reserve is already losing
trust
and people are questioning what their
motives are but if we were simply to
allow for a central bank digital
currency to be created by the central
bank and issued directly to americans
that would give the central bank and the
government the ability to know how much
money is in your bank account who are
you transacting with what are you
purchasing when how much that's
information that the government frankly
doesn't need it's an infringement on our
financial privacy
instead what we need is we need the
ability for americans to protect their
financial privacy we need the ability
for private enterprise to actually drive
innovation i don't want to trust the
central bank or my government to be
innovative i don't want them to be
competing on a global stage with other
companies in other countries when it
comes to technology the same people who
run the dmv
probably also who run our public health
policy who have proven themselves to be
incompetent in many ways why are we
going to trust them with a piece of
technology that quite literally our
country's reserve status
and also our place of economic
prosperity and leadership depends on
instead we're much better off having
private enterprise compete to produce
the single best asset and of course
bitcoin being a decentralized
transparent digital
open source project
has garnered over a trillion dollars of
value there's a reason why the free
market is determined bitcoin
specifically to have value
but also we have seen over a hundred
billion dollars of value flow into
stable coins those stable coins have the
same exact monetary policy as us dollars
but they're actually being created and
governed and distributed by private
companies the government isn't even
needed to actually get over 100 billion
dollars of value into these stable coins
and so if we're able to get the same end
result the same end benefit to users
around the world by using the private
enterprise rather than public
taxpayer money
or
organizations like the central bank
we probably should let the private
enterprises do what they do best compete
on the global stage because ultimately
the free market is going to be the
referee and we need to move quickly we
need to move efficiently and we need to
take this stuff seriously and so kudos
to representative emmer on his
courageous step to say listen
we should actually not ban bitcoin
ownership we should ban a central bank
digital currency being created and
distributed directly to americans by the
federal reserve